so they gave me Criminal damage to a
state supported location because I was
riding my skateboard down the sidewalk
and so when I went to court so I go to
jail and I'll tell you this very quickly
and then talk about you I go to jail and
I was there for I think it was like 16
hours I'm there and not even it's it's a
room the lights are on it's a concrete
block with a toilet connected to a water
faucet and that's it yeah they took all
the shoelaces uh anything that they they
took my uh uh I think I had an over
shirt like I'm wearing now and they took
my shoelaces off my shoes and so I used
my shoe as a pillow and I just laid
there
but uh I get out I ended up going to
court and uh the judge was like next in
the docket whatever everybody said you
know Timothy Poole and I stand up and he
was like so what's going on and then the
prosecutor standing with the the
security guys who had filed the
complaint said he was skateboarding at
this address and the judge looks down
and pulls the glass down he's like he
was what and then he was skateboarding
around and he goes
are you joking